on a pris les bonnes décisions je passe
dans les institutions européennes on a
pris les bonnes décisions mais
maintenant il faut les mettre en marche
il faut mettre les plan de relèvement et
résilients ça marche pour créer de
nouvelles opportunités on vas tu l'as
bien dit la priorité de la présidence
portugaise c'est là l'europe sociale
on va organiser un grand sommet social à
ma ville à porto dans le mois de mai et
je pense que le premier sujet de cette
union sociale c'est l'emploi l'emploi et
l'emploi avec des droits parce qu'il ya
aussi il a le problème de l'emploi mais
il faut pas accepter une espèce de
dumping social à propos de la crise qui
a été créé avec la panne est mais il
faut assurer que les emplois sont des
emplois avec des droits
[Musique]